Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. This episode of The Rest Is History on treason in modern Britain
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在 App 内订阅。本期《历史的余烬》关于现代英国的叛国罪
is sponsored by the National Archives. Enjoy the show. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And Tom, we are here again at the National Archives for their amazing exhibition, Treason, People, Power and Plot. And last time, we were talking about the Tudors and the medieval period and this time we've reached a real favorite of yours you love the the sort of 17th 18th centuries don't you I do and um I think we're going to be kicking off with um a subject that has already provided us with two episodes namely the the trial of Charles I. But we are actually looking at some of the documents that relate to that. We are. It's an amazing privilege, actually, to see these genuine, you know, the stuff of history without resorting completely into cliches. And this time we're joined by Neil
由国家档案馆（National Archives）赞助。节目开始。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。汤姆，我们再次来到国家档案馆，参观他们精彩绝伦的展览：“叛国罪：人民、权力与阴谋”（Treason, People, Power and Plot）。上次我们讨论了都铎王朝和中世纪，而这次我们迎来了你最喜欢的时期——你非常喜欢17、18世纪对吧？没错，而且我想我们首先要讨论的一个主题，其实之前已经为我们提供了两期节目，那就是查理一世的审判。但我们实际上是在看一些与此相关的原始文件。确实是的。能够看到这些真迹，也就是历史的实体，而不完全陷入陈词滥调，这真是一种极大的荣幸。这次我们邀请到了尼尔·约翰斯顿（Neil Johnston），
Johnston, who is absolutely top brain behind this exhibition, the head of the early modern archives here, I think. And Neil, sort of a dream of yours to see all this stuff out on public consumption? Oh, it's really wonderful to be able to put so many aspects of the collection together. Because archives are, you know, they're sort of abstract notions for people. What are they? Well, they're collections of records. And how do you try to explain it to people? And this collection is really, really remarkable. You know, where I'm from, the equivalent collection was blown up 100 years ago. So this to me is really, really special. Being able to go back to the 1352 Act, the treason act as it is, and even
他绝对是这次展览的幕后智囊，也是这里早期现代档案馆的负责人，我想是的。尼尔，看到所有这些东西公之于众，可以说是你的梦想吗？哦，能把藏品的这么多方面汇集在一起，感觉真是太棒了。因为对人们来说，档案馆毕竟是某种抽象的概念。它们是什么？嗯，它们是记录的集合。你该怎么向人们解释呢？而这个藏品真的、真的很非凡。你知道，我的家乡，同类藏品在100年前被炸毁了。所以对我和这来说，这真的、真的很特别。能够追溯到1352年的《叛国法》，也就是现在的叛国法，甚至
before that, as you can see in the exhibition, and then bring it all the way forward to the modern day. So the collection here in Britain is really, really special. It's remarkable. Well, but Neil, just before we recorded this, you showed us the record of parliamentary proceedings written in late 1649, 1650, detailing the events of the trial of Charles I. And it's in a kind of little brown book. And on the cover, it's got the trial of the king just in case anyone is any doubt as to it i mean it is incredible to see the physical documents that relate to this subject that dominate you and i you know we did these two episodes on absolutely up close i mean how does it make you feel when you look at you know it has the column of the people who are sitting in judgment on the king i mean how does it make you feel to see those names written down in ink on paper? Well, if you think of the importance of that event, in terms of legal
在此之前，正如你在展览中所看到的，然后一直延续到现代。所以英国的这个藏品真的、真的很特别。这太非凡了。尼尔，在我们录制这段音频之前，你给我们展示了1649年末、1650年初编写的议会会议记录，详细记录了查理一世审判的经过。它装在一个棕色的小本子里。封面上写着“国王的审判”，以防任何人对此产生任何怀疑。我的意思是，看到与这个主宰了你我的主题相关的实物文件，真的是太震撼了，你知道，我们做了那两期节目，简直是近距离接触。当你看这些记录时，那种感觉如何？你知道，上面有审判国王的陪审团成员的名单，当你在纸上看到那些用墨水写下的名字时，你是什么感觉？嗯，如果你考虑到这一事件在法律
history, in terms of political history, going and executing a monarch is an extremely rare event in any circumstances. So I wouldn't say, I wouldn't go so far to say it's quite moving, but you know, you can feel the importance of the event nearly coming off the page. You can see, like the journal is very, very detailed. It was written by the clerks who were there on each day during the trial of the house of commons and it authorizes and empowers itself to put the king on trial for treason so so could we look at it specifically in the context of treason the act of treason that we began the previous episode with 13 51 52 depending where you're coming from it the definition of treason is plotting against the king, not just compassing the death of the king, but imagining the death of the king. 1649, they're putting the king on trial. So presumably Edward III's act is hopeless for that because it brands them as traitors.
史和政治史上的重要性，处决一位君主在任何情况下都是极其罕见的事件。所以我不会说——我不会走得太远去说这有多么感人，但是，你知道的，你能感受到那一事件的重要性几乎要跃然纸上。你可以看到，比如日志非常、非常详细。它是由当时在场的书记员在下议院审判的每一天里撰写的，它授权并赋予自身权力，以叛国罪审判国王。所以，如果我们从叛国罪的特定背景来看，也就是我们在上一集节目开始时提到的那个叛国罪法案，根据你的理解，是1351年还是1352年，叛国罪的定义是密谋反对国王，不仅仅是图谋国王的死，而是构陷国王的死。1649年，他们正在审判国王。所以爱德华三世的那个法案对此毫无用处，因为这把他们打上了叛乱分子的烙印。
Well, it depends on how you view sovereignty. And the Commons claims sovereignty. It also has de facto authority because it's won the two civil wars. So it reverses the previous understanding of what treason is. Legally, yes, they are acting. It's extrajudicial, let's say. What they've done is illegal. Charles doesn't recognize the court, does he? The king refuses to recognize the authority of the courts to put him on trial.
嗯，这取决于你如何看待主权。下议院声称自己拥有主权。它还拥有事实上的权威，因为它赢得了两次内战。因此，它颠覆了以往对叛国罪的理解。从法律上讲，是的，他们的行为——我们姑且称之为越权审判吧。他们的所作所为是违法的。查理不承认这个法庭，对吧？国王拒绝承认法庭审理他的权威。
And he won't plead. And you can see that the court solicitors, John Cook, is almost barracking him to enter a plea because a case cannot initiate. So the court is very, very careful to follow the procedures that would ordinarily have been followed, say, for a treason trial or a murder trial. They are very, very clear on the proceedings proceedings but the king won't enter a plea so the case shouldn't actually continue but they ignore this. But what law would they, I mean what law can they bring? There is no law to bring.
而且他拒绝答辩。你可以看到法庭的诉讼律师约翰·库克（John Cook）几乎是在逼迫他进行抗辩，因为没有抗辩案件就无法开庭。因此，法庭非常、非常小心地遵循通常在叛国罪审判或谋杀审判中应遵循的程序。他们在诉讼程序上非常、非常明确，但国王拒绝答辩，所以案件本不应该继续下去，但他们忽略了这一点。不过他们能适用什么法律？我是说他们能搬出什么法律来？根本没有法律可适用。
So they claim authority. They claim that under the treason act the king by raising his banners he levied war on the people and the commons claimed that it was sovereign within the people. And the king had lost the right to claim this. So the pages you've chosen for us, is that what they're arguing, basically?
所以他们宣称自己拥有权威。他们声称，根据《叛国法》，国王通过竖起战旗，向人民发动了战争，而下议院声称自己在人民中拥有主权。国王已经失去了这样宣称的权利。所以你为我们挑选的页面，基本上就是他们在争论这个吗？
So this is, you can see Cook and the king arguing back and forth. The king refusing to accept that he had levied war, that he had committed treason. And Cook demanding, absolutely demanding that he enter levied war, that he had committed treason. And Cook demanding, absolutely demanding, that he enter the plea. Are they framing the idea of treason in a biblical context, a Roman context, an Anglo-Saxon context? I mean, where are they getting the idea that there is a case for the king to answer from? What's the legal underpinning for that case? The 1352 Act, the idea of levying war against the king,
所以，你可以看到库克和国王在来回争辩。国王拒绝承认他发动了战争，拒绝承认自己犯下了叛国罪。而库克则坚决要求、绝对要求他进行抗辩。等等，他们是在圣经背景、罗马背景还是盎格鲁-撒克逊背景下构建叛国罪概念的？我是说，他们认为国王有罪需要答辩的观点是从哪里来的？这一论点的法律基础是什么？1352年的法案，即发动针对国王的战争的概念，
is really what they're, against the people is what they're saying. But what they've tried to do is they've tried to perform this sort of jump to move, to shift the centre of authority from the crown, from the person of the king to the state. And that they say, as the commons of England, they are the true representatives of the people not the monarch and this is how they go forward and create a republic and that they say that they, it is the commons that is sovereign not the king. Now I'm not going to say it's not true
实际上是他们针对的是——他们说的是针对人民。但他们试图做的是，他们试图进行这种跳跃式转变，将权威的中心从王室、从国王个人转移到国家。他们说，作为英格兰的下议院，他们是人民真正的代表，而不是君主，这就是他们前进并建立共和国的方式，他们说，是下议院而不是国王拥有主权。现在我不会说这不是真的，
because they have the authority to do, they have defeated the royalist forces and so it's really about power and treason is theatre. Treason trials are generally theatre trials. So in the early modern period, the verdict is almost a foregone conclusion. So this wasn't, this was different. This was so unprecedented. It's not that they were making it up as they were going along, but they were adapting throughout the trial. But I suppose in a way they are the representative of the future
因为他们有权这样做，他们已经击败了保王党军队，所以这实际上关乎权力，而叛国罪是一场戏剧。叛国罪审判通常都是作秀审判。所以在早期现代，判决几乎是板上钉钉的。所以这不一样。这是史无前例的。倒不是说他们边走边编，而是他们在整个审判过程中不断调整。不过我想某种程度上他们是未来的代表，
because the idea that treason can be acted against an entire people, against a nation, is the future, isn't it? I mean, that is the understanding probably that most people have of it now. It's not specifically directed against the monarch. It's not against the person of the monarch necessarily anymore. And what we see here now is this shift into a more, both a more modern understanding of treason and also the beginning of the redundancy of the Treason Act as it was framed in 1352. So they have to adapt. And the commons or the rump of the long long parliament as it was who prosecuted the king they weren't the first or the last power we can say or government if we want to call them a government to adapt the
因为叛国罪可以针对全体人民、针对一个国家实施这种观念，就是未来，不是吗？我的意思是，这可能是现在大多数人对它的理解。它不再专门针对君主。它不一定再针对君主个人。而我们现在在这里看到的是，这种向更现代的叛国罪理解的转变，同时也是1352年制定的《叛国法》走向冗余的开始。所以他们必须适应。而下议院，或者说作为起诉国王的残缺的长议会（Rump of the Long Parliament），他们并不是第一批也不是最后一批可以说是政府——如果我们想称他们为政府的话——为了适应自身环境而修改叛国法的势力。
treason laws to their own circumstances so just on the document so when people come to the exhibition what they're actually seeing is something written not on the day but afterwards from from reports is that right there you write up the reports afterwards so the clerks within the commons will have been taking notes contemporary notes as events happened and then they will have written them up afterwards they were instructed by the house of commons to do this in february 1649 and it took about a year for that volume to emerge there's two or three volumes and they were they're heavily disputed but they are keenly important and they become even more important well i was about to say so fast
那么就这份文件而言，当人们来到展览时，他们实际看到的并不是当天写的东西，而是事后根据报告整理的，是这样吗？你是说事后写好报告？下议院的书记员会在事件发生当天做现场记录，然后在事后将它们整理出来。下议院在1649年2月指示他们这么做，这卷书花了大约一年的时间才问世。有两到三卷，它们备受争议，但极其重要，而且变得更加重要……我正想说呢，
forward to 1658 59 60 when you've got so much turbulence all the other alternatives exhaust themselves so suddenly becomes obvious that charles ii is basically the only alternative left is there no discussion about destroying these documents which actually are quite incriminating? The power has shifted. You know, Cromwell dies, Oliver Cromwell dies in September 1658 and his son takes over. But he doesn't have that authority to deal with the huge competing interests within the army, the Puritans within the army, within Parliament. Parliament itself doesn't want the army dictating to civilians.
快进到1658、1659、1660年，当时局势极度动荡，所有其他选择都筋疲力尽了，所以突然之间，查理二世基本上成了唯一的出路，难道没有人讨论过销毁这些实际上相当具有罪证的文件吗？权力已经转移了。你知道，克伦威尔死了，奥利弗·克伦威尔在1658年9月去世，他的儿子接替了他。但他没有那种权威来处理军队内部巨大的利益冲突，无论是军队内部的清教徒，还是议会内部的势力。议会本身不想被军队对平民发号施令。
The army doesn't want to be dictated to by civilians. So a form of political anarchy breaks out. And eventually, the last person who has legitimacy really to rule is Charles Stuart. He sidesteps very, very cleverly in 1660, the arguments that had been put forward in the 1640s that caused civil wars and the execution of his father. And as a new parliament emerges in 1660, in March and April 1660, they cannot agree on what's to happen. And an unlikely source had almost ended the republic which is general
军队也不想被平民指手画脚。于是某种政治无政府状态爆发了。最终，唯一真正拥有统治合法性的人是查理·斯图亚特（Charles Stuart）。他在1660年非常、非常巧妙地避开了1640年代引发内战以及处决他父亲的那些争论。随着1660年新议会的出现——在1660年3月和4月，他们无法就将要发生的事情达成一致。一个意想不到的源头差点终结了共和国，那就是将军
george monk who was the commander of the army in scotland his march on london in january february 1660 virtually ends the republic and a new parliament is assembled in march it was voted for in march 1660 and it meets the convention parliament meets in apr 1660. And Monk effectively says, anybody who is not for Charles Stuart, be silent. And this gives the king, the king had been in exile for 11 years at this point, Charles Stuart, who becomes Charles II, he sends his emissary, Sir John Grenville, on the 1st of May, 1660,
乔治·蒙克（George Monk），他是苏格兰军队的指挥官，他在1660年1月至2月进军伦敦，实际上终结了共和国。一个新的议会在3月组建，于1660年3月投票产生，并于1660年4月召开会议，即大会议（Convention Parliament）。蒙克实际上说：“任何不支持查理·斯图亚特的人，都闭嘴。”这给了国王——此时国王已经流亡了11年，也就是查理·斯图亚特，即后来的查理二世——他派遣密使约翰·格伦维尔爵士（Sir John Grenville）在1660年5月1日，
he hands in what's called his Declaration of Breda. And with this document, the king sidesteps everybody. It's a very, very clever piece of politics where he says, I will not refight the civil wars. I'm going to make parliament responsible for deciding who wins and loses about land that has exchanged hands over the last decade. And that's, it's a question they can't resolve. They tried to resolve it in ireland and it goes completely wrong for um almost three decades but thirdly and most importantly in many ways he says i will allow people to have liberty of conscience once they are not harming the kingdom so everybody who wants to conform to the teachings of the church of england they seem to be happy the puritans seem to be happy. They think they'll be okay.
递交了所谓的《布雷达宣言》（Declaration of Breda）。通过这份文件，国王把所有人晾在了一边。这是一场非常、非常高明的政治操作，他在其中说道：“我不会重新挑起内战。我要让议会负责决定在过去十年中易手的土地到底该由谁赢得、由谁失去。”这是一个他们无法解决的问题。他们在爱尔兰试图解决这个问题，结果却弄得一团糟，持续了将近三十年。但第三点、也是在许多方面最重要的一点是，他说：“只要不危害王国，我将允许人们拥有信仰自由。”因此，所有想要顺从英格兰教会教义的人似乎都很高兴，清教徒们也似乎很高兴。他们觉得自已会没事的。
Baptists and independents. So in this swoop, he sort of dismisses fears or grievances about him returning. But he also does something else very, very clever. He says, I will introduce an act of general pardon and indemnity and oblivion. I will indemnify people from being prosecuted for their actions in the 1640s, except for the 59 men who become known as the regicides. So that's what we have here. That's this act right here.
浸信会和独立派。所以在这个举动中，他某种程度上消除了人们对他回归的恐惧或不满。但他也做了另一件非常、非常聪明的事。他说：“我将颁布一项大赦、豁免和遗忘法案（Act of General Pardon and Indemnity and Oblivion）。我将免于起诉那些在1640年代采取行动的人，但那59名后来被称为弑君者（regicides）的人除外。”所以这就是我们这里有的东西。这就是那项法案。
That's the act of indemnity and oblivion. And pardon. Everybody except the 59 names on the previous document. Except, Neil, that they are not defined as regicides, are they? Regicide cannot be a crime. They're condemned as traitors. Yes. They, if we go back to the terms of the Treason Act, this 1352 Act, they compassed and imagined the death of the king in 1649. So what the law, as it is written
这就是豁免、遗忘和特赦法案。每个人都可以被特赦，除了上一份文件上的那59个名字。只是，尼尔，他们并没有被定义为弑君者，对吧？弑君不能算作一种罪行。他们被判为叛国罪。是的。他们——如果我们回到《叛国法》的条款，即1352年的法案，他们在1649年图谋和构陷了国王的死。所以摆在我们面前的成文法律规定，
in front of us, says those who were present on the the 27th of January 1649, the day sentence was passed on Charles I, and they're listed in front of us, these men are now guilty of treason. So this is the theme of Robert Harris's latest novel that's just come out about the hunt for the regicide. Lots of them get, is it 10, get rounded up and executed fairly briskly? So there's several phases. There's a proclamation issued in June 1660 saying all regicides are to hand themselves in. Some do, some don't. Some go on the run.
那些在1649年1月27日——即宣判查理一世死刑的那一天——在场的人，他们的名字就列在我们面前，这些人现在犯了叛国罪。所以这是罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris）刚出版的关于搜捕弑君者的小说的主题。他们中的很多人——是不是有10个人——被迅速搜捕并处决了？所以有几个阶段。1660年6月发布了一份公告，称所有弑君者都要自首。有些人照做了，有些人没有。有些人逃亡了。
Some are just detained by the Sergeant at Arms of Parliament and the Crown's authorities. And there's 19 trials in October. A special court is set up under the authority of the court, the King's Bench. And that's the one that includes Thomas Harrison who peeps and watches and he looked as cheerful as could be expected under the circumstances.
有些人只是被议会和王室权力的军士长（Sergeant at Arms）拘留了。10月份有19场审判。根据王座法庭（King's Bench）的权威设立了一个特别法庭。其中包括托马斯·哈里森（Thomas Harrison），他偷窥并注视着，在那种情况下他显得尽可能地快活。
Harrison is executed in October 1649 because he's accepted from the act of indemnity and general pardon. And also what they do is they dig up Cromwell and Henry Art and his son-in-law and various other figures who've died. And the president of the court, John Bradshaw. Yeah, and they kind of chop their heads off and stick them on spikes and things. John Bradshaw's steel hat, Tom, that we talked about in that podcast, availed him naught in the end. Yes, and then two escape to America, and that's the theme of Robert Harris' novel. Yeah, that's the theme of...
哈里森于1649年10月被处决，因为他被排除在特赦和普遍宽恕法案之外。他们还把克伦威尔、亨利·艾尔顿（Henry Ireton，他的女婿）以及其他几个已经去世的人物从坟墓里挖了出来。还有法庭庭长约翰·布拉德肖（John Bradshaw）。是的，他们把他们的头砍下来插在长矛上之类的。约翰·布拉德肖的铁帽子，汤姆，我们在那个播客里谈到过，最后对他也毫无用处。是的，然后有两个人逃到了美国，这就是罗伯特·哈里斯小说的主题。是的，那是……
But they kind of get bored of it, don't they? america and that's the theme of robert harris is normally yeah yeah that's the theme of but they kind of get bored of it don't they um after you know after a while they um so there's a spy master um what's his name the guy who founds downing college yes um and he's very treacherous and he's the ambassador in the hague and he persuades three um of the regicides to come under the under the pretense that he will pair them up with their wives arrests them takes them back to london and people are revolted essentially by the um by the display of execution about that do you think among the public at large i know it's impossible to say with any degree of certitude but do you think there was among the public at large there was a
但他们有点对这个厌倦了，不是吗？……美国，这就是罗伯特·哈里斯小说的主题。是的，是的，那是……但他们有点对这个厌倦了，不是吗？……在经历了，你知道，过了一段时间后，他们……所以有一个间谍头子，他叫什么名字？那个创立唐宁学院（Downing College）的人。是的，他非常阴险，他是海牙的大使，他劝说三名弑君者前来，借口是帮他们与妻子团聚，然后逮捕他们，把他们带回伦敦。而公众基本上对这种处决展示感到反感。你认为在广大公众中——我知道无法以任何绝对的确定性来说明——你认为在广大公众中是否存在这样一种感觉：
sense you know they had it coming you know what comes around goes around you know that's or do you think people thought that this was vindictive on the bath of charles the answer is actually both those who witnessed the executions when you read peeps's diaries and the diaries of others contemporary at the time in the correspondence such was the gore of the executions in october 1660 after these trials these treason trials trials. You know, being hung, drawn and quartered, disemboweled, the intestines being thrown onto a barbecue for all intents. And the smell seemingly around Charing Cross
“他们这是罪有应得，风水轮流转，这就是……”还是你认为人们觉得这是查理的报复心理？答案其实是两者兼有。那些目睹了处决过程的人——当你阅读佩皮斯（Pepys）的日记以及当时同时代的其他人、在书信中的日记时，1660年10月这些审判、这些叛国罪审判之后的处决是多么血腥。你知道的，被绞死、剖腹并五马分尸，内脏被扔到烤架上烧烤，可以说是惨不忍睹。查林十字（Charing Cross）周围的恶臭
was disgusting. And people who had been, the tide very quickly turns and the crown on the authorities had to be very, very wary of this. You know, people are having their heads chopped off. There's blood everywhere in and around Charing Cross where the execution's looking down towards Banqueting House where the king has been executed. And as the rich sides themselves knew that large congregations of people meeting to watch executions are potentially very dangerous.
似乎令人作呕。而人们原本——风向很快就变了，王室和当局不得不对此非常、非常警惕。你知道，人们被砍头。查林十字街里里外外到处都是血，处决地正对着宴会厅（Banqueting House），国王就是在那里被处决的。正如弑君者自已所知，大量人群聚集观看处决具有潜在的巨大危险。
Absolutely. So on the issue of hanging, drawing and quartering male traitors. You are absolutely obsessed with this. No, I'm not, Dominic. And burning female traitors. When does that finish? So when do people start to think, okay, we should deal with traitors,
绝对的。那么关于对男性叛国者处以绞刑、剖腹和分尸的问题。你对这个绝对着迷。没有，多米尼克，我没有。还有烧死女性叛国者。那是什么时候结束的？人们是什么时候开始觉得，好吧，我们应该处理叛国者，
but we're not going to ritually torture them to death in the way that we had been doing? When does that? As far as I'm aware, Peter's out in the 18th century. It just becomes unpalatable. For kind of enlightenment reasons? Well, I was about to say, in some ways you could argue this is a pretty extraordinary document.
但我们不会像以前那样对他们进行仪式性的酷刑折磨致死了？那是什么时候？据我所知，在18世纪逐渐淡出了。它只是变得令人无法接受。是出于某种启蒙运动的原因吗？嗯，我正想说，从某种程度上你可以认为这是一份非常非凡的文件。
The act of indemnity and oblivion. Because couldn't you make the case that there is clearly a tipping point after which it no longer is really the done thing to execute your enemies. To accuse your enemies of being traitors. There's a move towards,
《豁免与遗忘法案》。因为难道你不能说，这里显然存在一个转折点，在此之后，处决你的敌人不再真正是一件做得体的事了吗？不再将你的敌人指控为叛国者了吗？人们开始转向，
I guess, I know this is very anachronistic, but a more pluralistic kind of political arena where ministers rise and fall, where your opponents may be a first of all, they go into exile like Bolingbroke did, um, at the end of the reign of Queen Anne, but he then comes back.
我猜——我知道这非常不合时宜——转向一个更加多元化的政治舞台，在这里大臣们起起伏伏，在这里你的对手也许首先会流亡，就像博林布鲁克（Bolingbroke）在安妮女王统治末期所做的那样，但他后来又回来了。
He's not beheaded. There's a sort of move away from spectacular violence I suppose but also the idea of you know his majesty's loyal opposition I suppose comes in
他没有被斩首。我想这算是一种远离耸人听闻的暴力的转变，但同时也引入了“陛下忠诚的反对派”的概念吧？
well yeah you get kind of competing parties so in that I think that's we're maybe getting slightly ahead of ourselves but just by a couple of decades
嗯，是的，你会得到某种相互竞争的政党。所以在这点上，我想我们可能有点操之过急了，不过也就超前了几十年。
right at this point the king knows he has to limit very very clearly Charles is much I would say he's much more politically astute than his father.
就在这个时候，国王知道他必须非常、非常明确地进行限制。查理比他父亲在政治上要精明得多。
He's less dogmatic. He could hardly be less astute, right? Well, yeah, he's less dogmatic than his father. And that's certainly true. And he's probably more wily. And he doesn't stand on ceremony the way his father did. So he was willing, we presume, you know, the king didn't write these things down,
他没有那么教条。他几乎不可能比他父亲更不精明了吧？嗯，是的，他比他父亲不那么教条。这绝对是真的。而且他可能更狡猾。他不像他父亲那样讲究礼节。所以我们推测他愿意——国王没有把这些事情写下来，
but we presume he was willing to accept a limited form of retribution. Because how does someone whose father has been executed and been forced into exile for over a decade, how do they respond? And this is how he responds. He never would have been effectively summoned back if he had said, I'm coming in with an army. And what army would have fought for him necessarily too? So it's at the end of his reign, we see the emergence of proto-political parties.
但我们推测他愿意接受一种有限度的报复形式。因为一个父亲被处决、自己被迫流亡十多年的人，会如何回应？这就是他的回应。如果他说“我是带着军队回来的”，他绝对不可能被有效地召回。而且到底会有哪支军队必然为他而战呢？所以在他的统治末期，我们看到了准政党的出现。
Yeah. The Whigs and the Tories. But this has got a treason connection too, right? It certainly does. So you've got a document here. I think this is, of all your documents, this is one of my absolute favorites because it's one of, I mean,
是的。辉格党和托利党。但这也有一个叛国罪的联系，对吧？当然有。所以你这里有一份文件。我想在你的所有文件中，这是我绝对最喜欢的文件之一，因为它是一份——
we haven't covered this in the rest of history. We touched on it. As much as we should have. It's a title out. Because it is one of, I mean we haven't covered this in the rest of history. We touched on Titus Oates. Because it is one of the great stories in all English history. Which of course relates to the porridge murderer that we mentioned in the... Porridge. Yes, porridge. Unexpected theme. Talk to us about the
我们还没有在《历史的余烬》中讨论过这个。我们只是略微触及了一下。正如我们本该做的那样。这是一个大新闻。因为它是——我的意思是，我们还没有在《历史的余烬》中讨论过这个。我们提到了蒂图斯·奥茨（Titus Oates）。因为它是整个英国历史上最伟大的故事之一。这当然与我们在……中提到的“粥杀手”（porridge murderer）有关。粥。是的，粥。意想不到的主题。跟我们聊聊
Popish Plot. Popish Plot is this remarkable episode or event in English and British and Irish history whereby this man Titus Oates concocts a series of lies about Jesuits, about Catholics
“阴谋杀王案”（Popish Plot）吧。天主教阴谋案是英国、不列颠和爱尔兰历史上一个非凡的插曲或事件，这个名叫蒂图斯·奥茨的家伙捏造了一系列关于耶稣会士、关于天主教徒的谎言，
it's his macabre fantasy really that emerges. It's a kind of late 17th century QAnon perhaps Conspiracy most certainly it's hard to get your head around it. Oates had tried to train at Cambridge in the Church of England.
这实际上是他的可怕幻想。这也许有点像17世纪晚期的QAnon阴谋论。确实如此，很难理解。奥茨曾试图在剑桥的英国国教接受培训。
He was thrown out of Cambridge. He lies and says that he was successful and he graduated and he's given a living in the Church of England. He's thrown out of that. He has to run away. He becomes chaplain to the garrison of Tangier in the 1670s. He's thrown out of there. He then, he's sent back, he arrives back in London destitute and he falls in with Catholics in London and he starts to learn about the activities of the Jesuits. He's sent then by
他被剑桥开除了。他撒谎说自己成功毕业了，并在英国国教获得了一份神职。他又被那里的神职开除了。他不得不逃跑。在1670年代，他成为了丹吉尔（Tangier）卫戍部队的随军牧师。他又被从那里开除了。然后他——他被遣返回伦敦，回到伦敦时已一贫如洗，并与伦敦的天主教徒混在一起，开始了解耶稣会士的活动。接着他被派遣
the provincial of the Jesuits to train as a Catholic priest first of all to Spain, to Salamanca. He's thrown out of there. His behavior is terrible. He's no Latin. He keeps getting drunk. He's fighting with people. He's very father-tongue. If you want to put it that way, yes.
由耶稣会士的省会长（provincial）派去培训成为天主教神父，首先是去西班牙的萨拉曼卡。他从那里被开除了。他的行为糟透了。他不会拉丁语。他不断酗酒。他跟人打架。他说话非常口无遮拦——如果你想这么说的话，是的。
He's drinking the toilet duck. And he comes back to England and then he's sent to Northern France to train again. This falls apart and the principals in the college in Saint he's sent to Northern France to train again. This falls apart and the principles in the college in Saint-Omer in Northern France say, be gone. He arrives back in London.
他喝洗厕灵。然后他回到英国，接着被派往法国北部再次接受培训。这又泡汤了，位于法国北部圣奥梅尔（Saint-Omer）的学院的负责人对他说：滚蛋吧。他回到了伦敦。
Again, he's destitute. But what he actually has now is just enough knowledge of what may be seen as a Catholic conspiracy. The infrastructure of the Jesuits in London. So when we look back to the Popish plot and the plots against Elizabeth's reign, these Reformation, counter-Reformation plots
同样，他身无分文。但他现在真正拥有的，只是对天主教阴谋——伦敦耶稣会士基础设施——的微末了解。所以当我们回看天主教阴谋案以及针对伊丽莎白统治的阴谋时，这些宗教改革、反宗教改革的阴谋，
that were happening in the 16th and very early 17th centuries, this is kind of, this revives all that, this fear of encirclement. But it also happens during a time when Charles II's religious policies, which were never properly determined after the Restoration, rise again because his brother, James, the Duke of York,
发生在16世纪和17世纪初的那些事，这在某种程度上复活了这一切，这种被包围的恐惧。但这同时也发生在一个时期，查理二世的宗教政策——在王政复辟后从未得到彻底确定——再次抬头，因为他的弟弟、约克公爵詹姆斯（James, the Duke of York），
is outed effectively from the mid-1670s as a Catholic. The Test Act in 1673 demanded that everybody who holds office in England must take communion within the Church of England, and he refuses to. So all of a sudden, there's a crisis at the top of government because a Catholic may be about to succeed. So Oates' concoctions, his lies, his fabrications, his conspiracy theories are brought to the fore by men who want to embarrass Charles II
在1670年代中期实际上被曝光为天主教徒。1673年的《测试法案》（Test Act）要求所有在英格兰担任公职的人必须在英国国教领圣餐，而他拒绝了。所以突然之间，政府高层出现了危机，因为一个天主教徒可能即将继位。因此，奥茨捏造的谎言、虚构的故事和阴谋论被那些想要让查理二世难堪、并将他的弟弟詹姆斯排除在继承权之外的人推到了风口浪尖。而天主教阴谋案是被称为“排除危机”（exclusion crisis）的更大危机的一部分。那么这里这份文件是什么？所以这是一本神奇的书。同样，它就像一本巨大的日志，手写，羊皮纸上的墨水……纸上的墨水。
and exclude his brother James from the succession. And the Popish plot is part of a larger crisis that we call the exclusion crisis. And so what's this document here? So this is an amazing kind of book. Again, it's like a massive journal, handwritten, ink on parchment. Ink on paper. Ink on paper. This is paper.
纸上的墨水。这是纸。
And what is it? So Oates is summoned. He brings his allegations. He has them notarized, and he brings them to the attention of the Privy Council. The king himself kind of dismisses it. Charles says, no, this is nonsense. But he asks his chief minister, the Earl of Danby, to investigate.
这是什么？所以奥茨被传唤了。他提出了他的指控。他进行了公证，并把它们提交给枢密院（Privy Council）。国王本人对此不屑一顾。查理说，不，这是无稽之谈。但他要求他的首席大臣、丹比伯爵（Earl of Danby）进行调查。
Danby can't turn up anything, but still they are worried that it might be true. So Oates himself is brought before the Privy Council at the end of September 1678 and into October when he unleashes his allegations. And the ministers and the councillors who really, to be honest with you, should have known better
丹比查不出任何东西，但他们仍然担心这可能是真的。因此，奥茨本人在1678年9月底到10月被带到枢密院，在那里他抛出了他的指控。而那些说实话本该更有见识的大臣和参事们，
run with this. Because as I say, he has just enough knowledge. And he makes allegations against Jesuits who he knows. The cornerstone of the Popish plot is... And presumably people want to believe this. Yes. I mean, you know, he's pushing against an open door in terms of... And he makes allegations that a conspiracy was hatched in May 1678
却对此信以为真。因为正如我所说，他掌握了恰到好处的了解。而且他指控了他认识的耶稣会士。天主教阴谋案的基石是……而且人们想必愿意相信这一点。是的。我的意思是，你知道，就……而言，他在推开一扇虚掩的门。他指控说，一个阴谋于1678年5月
at the White Horse Tavern on the Strand, and that Jesuits were there, Louis XIV, the French king who Charles II is effectively in league with now. Louis is going to pay for an invasion force to overthrow the Protestant succession and place James on the throne. That's the corner of it. It's nonsense.
在河岸街（Strand）的白马酒馆（White Horse Tavern）策划，耶稣会士们都在场，法国国王路易十四——查理二世现在实际上正与他勾结——路易将出资一支入侵部队，推翻新教继承权并扶植詹姆斯登上王位。这就是核心。这简直是胡扯。
But he gets a couple of things right by fluke or whatever, doesn't he? Two things in particular. So he makes all these allegations and the notebook is, it's the clerk for the Privy Council trying to keep track of the allegations that are being made
但他凭运气或其他什么原因猜对了一两件事，不是吗？尤其是两件事。所以他提出了所有这些指控，这个笔记本——是枢密院的书记员试图记录正在提出的指控，
and those who are being detained and arrested and charged with treason. And it runs for 70 or 80 pages of warrants are issued for so-and-so's arrest. But the two things that Oates, I'm not going to say gets right, but he gets lucky with. The first one is Edward Coleman. Edward Coleman was in James's entourage
以及那些被拘留、逮捕并被控犯有叛国罪的人。它有七八十页，上面满是对某某人发出逮捕令的记录。但奥茨——我不会说他猜对了，但他运气好碰上的两件事。第一件是爱德华·科尔曼（Edward Coleman）。爱德华·科尔曼是詹姆斯随从人员的一部分，
and he had corresponded in 1673 and 74 with one of Louis XIV's confessors, Mr. Le Chasse, his name was. Coleman is detained. An order goes out to search for his papers. And in these papers, we see Coleman saying, I could facilitate the overthrow of the Protestant crown.
他在1673年和1674年曾与路易十四的一位忏悔神父——名字叫勒沙斯先生（Mr. Le Chaise）——有过通信联系。科尔曼被拘留了。搜查他文件的命令下达了。在这些文件中，我们看到科尔曼说：“我可以促成新教王冠的推翻。”
Oh, my God. Yes. So that is lucky for Oates, right? I guess a stuck clock tells the right time to stay. To give you a parallel, it's like a 1950s McCarthyite saying that 100 members of the State Department are communists, and one of them turns out is a fellow traveller. You know, that's not insight. That's just pure luck and coincidence.
天哪。是的。所以这对奥茨来说很走运，对吧？我想，坏掉的钟一天也能准两次。打个比方，这就像一个1950年代的麦卡锡主义者说国务院有100名成员是共产主义者，结果其中一个人真的是同路人。你知道，那不是洞察力，那纯粹是运气和巧合。
That's what happens here. And what we see happening is everything else seems to fall into place then for Oates. And he is sort of emboldened by this. And he makes more and more outlandish accusations. The second thing that happens is that Justice Berry, who notarized the initial allegations, he's found dead. And it's still an unexplained murder. So all of a sudden, Oates becomes the saviour of Protestant England, and the justice becomes a martyr from Protestant England. We also get the Polish plot moving from the private political arena, from the private arena into the political parliament.
这就是这里发生的事情。我们看到的是，其他一切似乎都对奥茨有利了。他因此受到了鼓舞。他提出了越来越多的荒诞指控。发生的第二件事是，对最初的指控进行公证的贝里法官（Justice Berry）被发现死亡。这至今仍然是一起未解谋杀案。因此，突然之间，奥茨成为了新教英格兰的救世主，而这位法官则成为了新教英格兰的烈士。天主教阴谋案也从私人政治舞台、从私人领域转移到了政治议会。
The House of Commons and the House of Lords starts to champion Oates, and Oates all of a sudden has an audience of the most powerful people in the realm. And this book is the clerks in the council. And it's one of the wonders of this archive because we have all the major papers, like the Acts of Parliament and whatnot. But we also have the official papers of the men who worked for the government. And it's how we try to rebuild this story. But to put this on the
下议院和上议院开始支持奥茨，奥茨突然拥有了由王国中最有权势的人组成的听众。这本书是枢密院书记员的记录。它是这个档案馆的奇迹之一，因为我们拥有所有主要文件，比如议会法案等等。但我们也有为政府工作的人的官方文件。这就是我们试图重建这个故事的方式。但要把这个放到
sort of biggest stage of all you could argue that from for example that book we get politics because the wigs and taurus you know a lot of historians would trace them back to the arguments following the popish plot about if james duke of york should be excluded from the throne correct the succession crisis that happens as they try to embarrass the king. And as Shaftesbury, the Earl of Shaftesbury, Anthony Ashley Cooper, the Earl of Shaftesbury, he champions Oates. Now, the trials proceed from late 1678.
最大的舞台上，你可以说，例如从那本书中，我们得到了政治，因为辉格党和托利党——很多历史学家会将它们追溯到天主教阴谋案后关于约克公爵詹姆斯是否应被排除出王位继承权的争论，没错，也就是他们在试图让国王难堪时发生的继承危机。随着沙夫茨伯里伯爵（Earl of Shaftesbury）、安东尼·阿什利·库珀（Anthony Ashley Cooper）、沙夫茨伯里伯爵支持奥茨。现在，审判从1678年底开始进行。
Oates moves from the political arena into the legal arena, and his story really falls apart then. And we can see the Lord Chief Justice of the Court of Kings bench and the legal officials nearly aiding and assisting him in corroborating these stories, these allegations against these Catholics, these Jesuits who are really not guilty of treason. But they're charged, they're condemned, and they're executed. And those records all exist within within the collection so we can follow this trial these trials but it becomes publicly apparent that oats is a liar i mean he ends up in the pillory doesn't he and we have trial by propaganda here he does eventually yeah he he perjures himself and james pursues him so in the long run i mean does that leave people embarrassed?
奥茨从政治舞台转向法律舞台，他的谎言从那时起真正瓦解了。我们可以看到王座法庭的首席大法官和法律官员几乎在协助和支持他，以证实这些对天主教徒、对那些根本没有犯下叛国罪的耶稣会士的指控、这些谎言。但他们被起诉、被定罪并被处决。而这些记录全都存在于藏品中，所以我们可以追踪这场审判、这些审判，但公众逐渐看清了奥茨是个骗子——我的意思是，他最后上了耻辱柱，不是吗？我们在这里上演了一场宣传审判。他最终确实上了耻辱柱，是的，他作伪证，詹姆斯对穷追不舍。所以从长远来看，我的意思是，这会让人们感到尴尬吗？
Do they feel, oh God, we believed all this rubbish? And does that have a kind of knock-on effect on the readiness to believe accusations of treason and perhaps undermine the very concept of treason, do you think, through the late 17th going into the 18th century? Well, it certainly emboldens Charles II and it consolidates his position. And in reality, it emboldens James's position too. They ride this out. As he becomes James II, his own political mistakes, let's say,
他们会觉得，“天哪，我们竟然相信了所有这些垃圾”吗？这是否会产生一种连锁反应，影响人们相信叛国指控的意愿，并或许在17世纪末到18世纪期间破坏了叛国罪的概念本身，你觉得呢？嗯，它当然坚定了查理二世的决心，并巩固了他的地位。实际上，它也坚定了詹姆斯的决心。他们渡过了这个难关。随着他成为詹姆斯二世，他自己的政治失误——我们可以这样说——
continue to revive these fears of Catholic threats. And he is undone by his own government and he's forced into exile. But he's not called a traitor, right? James II is not called a traitor when he leaves. He's just, the fiction is created that he had fled his... Well, he'd thrown away the Great Seal, hadn't he? Right, abandoned his post, yeah, effectively.
继续唤醒人们对天主教威胁的恐惧。他被自己的政府打倒，被迫流亡。但他没有被称为叛国者，对吧？詹姆斯二世离开时并没有被称为叛国者。他只是——人们制造了一个虚构的说法，说他抛弃了他的……嗯，他把国玺扔掉了，不是吗？对，放弃了他的职务，是的，实际上是这样。
That's one of the things that you're not allowed to do. I mean, that's the treason under the original Treason Act. You're not allowed to put seals in the river. You're not allowed to put seals in the river, no. So I don't know whether that had any... It never needed to because he was gone. You know, gone from England. Not the river, no. So I don't know whether that had any... It never needed to, because he was gone. You know, gone from England, not gone from, let's say, Ireland, where we know what happened there,
那是你不被允许做的事情之一。我的意思是，那是原始《叛国法》下的叛国罪。你不被允许把国玺扔进河里。你不被允许把国玺扔进河里，是的。所以，我不知道这是否有任何……根本不需要，因为他已经走了。你知道，离开英格兰了。不是河，是的。所以，我不知道这是否有任何……根本不需要，因为他已经走了。你知道，离开英格兰，而不是离开——比方说爱尔兰，我们知道那里发生了什么，
and the consequences of the fighting that happened in Ireland that still permeates to this day. Well, perhaps I think we should have a break at this point, but when we come back, we could look at the implications of the Treason Act for Ireland, but also um for the the the colonies um in north america and the terrible treasonous activity that breaks out there towards the end of the 18th century so we will see you back very soon bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment
以及爱尔兰战斗的后果，这些后果至今仍然弥漫着。好吧，也许我认为我们应该在这个时候休息一下，但当我们回来时，我们可以探讨《叛国法》对爱尔兰的影响，还有对北美殖民地的影响，以及18世纪末在那里爆发的可怕的叛国活动。所以我们很快就会回来，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about all kinds of treasonous behaviour.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、秀场八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在讨论各种各样的叛国行为。
And Tom, we are reaching perhaps the worst episode. The most shocking example. Of treachery. And treachery, it's not just treachery, it's treachery and tax evasion, I think we can safely say. Terrible behaviour. In British history. Because you have here, Neil, so Neil is with us from the National Archives talking about their amazing exhibition. You have here a copy of the ultimate treasonous document, which is, of course, the Declaration of Independence.
汤姆，我们正在接近也许是最糟糕的一集。最令人震惊的背叛例子。背叛，这不仅仅是背叛，这是背叛加上逃税，我想我们可以这么说。英国历史上糟糕透顶的行为。因为你这里有，尼尔——尼尔和我们一起从国家档案馆来，谈论他们精彩的展览。你这里有一份终极叛国文件的副本，当然，那就是《独立宣言》。
There it is right in front of you. And again, it's another one of these real turning points in the exhibition as we were thinking about how we would draw in material from the 18th century. We're further moving the story along by thinking about how we're moving away from the person, again, of the monarch under the Treason Act and into the state. So we can see here, the document is obviously 1776, but we have wonderful materials that surround it from the mid to late 18th century that show us the change in society that is emerging, these Enlightenment ideas, these ideas of independence, of moving away from monarchy, of moving, of self-determination. And we know that the Americans, the colonists, let's call them, initially in the 1750s and 1760s, their disgruntlement was with taxation, with not
就在你面前。再说一次，这也是展览中又一个真正的转折点，当时我们在思考如何将18世纪的材料融入其中。通过思考我们如何再次摆脱《叛国法》下君主的个人形象，并将其转变为国家，我们进一步推进了这个故事。所以我们可以看到，这份文件显然是1776年的，但我们周围有许多来自18世纪中后期的精彩材料，向我们展示了正在兴起的社会变革、这些启蒙运动的思想、独立思想、摆脱君主制的思想、以及自我决定的思想。我们知道，美国人，也就是殖民者，我们不妨这么称呼他们，最初在18世纪50年代和60年代，他们的不满在于税收，在于没有
having representation at Westminster, but yet taxes were being levied on them. And so these were economic frustrations rather than Republican ideas. And it was the escalation of this argument between the Crown and the colonists over who had the right to self-determination, the Americans arguing that they should be allowed to tax themselves, they should be allowed justice. It really got difficult when the Crown legislated that anybody who was deemed to be a traitor in the Americas should be brought to England for trial.
在威斯敏斯特获得代表权，然而税收却一直在向他们征收。因此，这些是经济上的挫折，而不是共和思想。随着王室和殖民者之间关于谁拥有自决权的争论不断升级——美国人认为他们应该被允许自己纳税，他们应该被允许获得公正——当王室立法规定任何被认为在美洲是叛国者的人都应该被带到英国受审时，情况真的变得困难了。
The Americans arguing that they should have trial by their peers. The colonists arguing this. Just to be absolutely clear, the provisions of the 1351 Act of Treason apply in British North America. So when they take a stand against their rightful king, they are traitors. It's in the charters.
美国人认为他们应该由同龄人陪审团审判。殖民者们据此争辩。为了绝对清楚起见，《1351年叛国法》的条款适用于英属北美。因此，当他们反抗合法的国王时，他们就是叛国者。这在特许状里写着。
The charters that created the colonies, yes. But when they declare independence, then suddenly people who are keeping loyal to the king are becoming the traitors. So it's a kind of replay of what happens when Richard II gets deposed and suddenly people who'd been loyal to Richard II are the
创建殖民地的特许状，是的。但当他们宣布独立时，那些保持对国王忠诚的人突然变成了叛国者。所以这有点像理查二世被废黜时重演的一幕，当时忠于理查二世的人突然变成了
traitors and are condemned as such by Henry IV. And you're seeing the same kind of drama playing out at the end of the 18th century but on an Atlantic scale. The Americans legislate for it and they incorporate the Treason Act into their constitution. That's the only criminal law
叛国者，并被亨利四世这样定罪。你会在18世纪末看到同样的戏剧性场面在大西洋规模上演。美国人为其立法，并将《叛国法》纳入他们的宪法。这是唯一的刑法
in the US founding document. That's right. The Treason Act is the only criminal law in the US founding document. That's right. The Treason Act is the only criminal law at the dawn of the United States. But they say
在美国的建国文献中。没《叛国法》是美国建国文献中唯一的刑法。没错。《叛国法》是美国诞生之初唯一的刑法。但他们说
it's not against the monarch. They rephrase it to be levying war against the Republic. I think that's the term they use. Right. And so do you think that's a slight...
这不是针对君主的。他们将其重新表述为对共和国发动战争。我想这是他们用的词。没错。所以你认为这是一个轻微的……
Can we trace a thread from the trial of Charles V? Certainly. They directly reference it. And they say that Parliament imposed itself on the monarch and we're going to do the same. But again, we compared the original Treason Act to Magna Carta.
我们能从查理五世的审判中找到一条线索吗？当然可以。他们直接引用了它。他们说议会把意志强加给君主，我们也要这么做。不过话说回来，我们将最初的《叛国法》与《大宪章》进行了比较。
And I guess it's faintly similar, the way that Magna Carta underpins a lot of American constitutional legal understanding. The Treason Act presumably is playing the same, it's a kind of disguised foundation stone for how the American state comes to define and oppose what it calls treason. Well, it's less prominent, but yes, things like, you know, the continuation of the idea of habeas corpus and that, you can't be detained without just cause cause for instance you can't just be randomly detained you know and it's it is the suspension of things like the habeas corpus act
我想这有点相似，《大宪章》支撑了美国宪法法律理解的很多方面。据推测，《叛国法》也发挥了同样的作用，它是美国国家如何定义和反对它所谓的叛国行为的一种隐蔽的基石。嗯，它没那么显眼，但是是的，比如，你知道的，人身保护令思想的延续，以及你不能无正当理由被拘留，例如，你不能无缘无故地被任意拘留，你知道的，正是诸如人身保护令法案之类的事情的暂停
in north america that caused such frustration that caused such anger amongst the colonists and that but they then incorporate all these ideas into their own constitution and so we talked about america but i'm guessing that guessing that you as a Dubliner would have a particular interest in another fracture point of British, the writ of the British treason law, which would be Ireland. Which, and as I understand it,
在北美引发了如此大的挫败感，在殖民者中引发了如此大的愤怒，但他们随后将所有这些 ideas 融入到他们自己的宪法中，所以我们讨论了美国，但我猜，我猜你作为一个都柏林人，会对英国不列颠叛国法管辖权的另一个断裂点特别感兴趣，那就是爱尔兰。据我了解，
the provisions of Edward III's Treason Act applied to Ireland from 1495, is it? That's right, yeah, there is the Treason Act from then. So Ireland, if we're talking about the late 18th century, the movements for determination in Ireland kind of mirror what happened in the United, what becomes the United States and are heavily influenced then by the French Revolution, these ideas of liberty. In Ireland, there is from the late 1780s into the 1790s, there's this idea of
爱德华三世的《叛国法》的条款是从1495年开始适用于爱尔兰的，对吗？没错，是的，从那时起就有《叛国法》了。所以爱尔兰，如果我们谈论的是18世纪末，爱尔兰的自决运动在某种程度上反映了联合王国（后来的美国）发生的事情，并且深受法国大革命和这些自由思想的影响。在爱尔兰，从1780年代末到1790年代，存在着这样一种想法：
some sort of self-determination. And we witnessed the propagation of ideas around not yet the creation of a republic, not initially the creation of a republic, but parliamentary reform, allowing Catholics to sit as MPs, allowing the complete revocation of what are known as the penal laws that stipulated that Catholics couldn't be represented in Parliament by their own peers. They had to, it was Protestant. So the complications of ascendancy Ireland,
某种形式的自决权。我们见证了各种思想的传播，当时还不是建立共和国，最初也不是为了建立共和国，而是议会改革，允许天主教徒成为议员，允许彻底废除被称为刑法的法律，该法律规定天主教徒不能由自己的同龄人在议会中代表。他们必须是新教徒。因此，统治阶级爱尔兰的复杂性，
18th century Ireland, really come to a head at the end, inspired by France, inspired by America. And men like Theobald Wolftone, they establish in October 1791 the Society for the United Irishmen. Just a month before here in London, Thomas Hardy establishes the London Correspondence. Not the novelist, the polemicist, let's say, Thomas Hardy. And these ideas, these radical reforming societies, popular political organisations that are seeking to really expand the franchise and allow much more self-determination. These ideas that emerge in America and France and then, of course, are seeping into England, but they are a huge threat to the British establishment. Well, okay, but Thomas Hardy, he's what?
18世纪的爱尔兰，在法国和美国的启发下，在末期真正达到了白热化。西奥博尔德·沃尔夫·托恩等人于1791年10月建立了联合爱尔兰人社团。就在一个月前，托马斯·哈代在这里的伦敦创立了伦敦通讯社。不是那个小说家，而是那个论辩家，姑且这么说吧，托马斯·哈代。这些思想，这些激进的改革社团、大众政治组织，都在寻求真正扩大选举权并允许更多的自决权。这些在美法两国兴起、随后自然也渗入英国的思想，对英国当权派构成了巨大的威胁。好吧，但是托马斯·哈代，他是什么人？
He's a shoemaker, is he? So he's brought to trial on the charge of treason. But basically, he's just arguing for radical change, isn't he? I mean, he's not arguing for the overthrow of the monarchy. But the argument against that, not the counter-argument, would be it's taking place at a time of tremendous international turmoil. So in other words, those ideas are identified with the enemy that Britain is fighting. Yeah, I absolutely see that.
他是个鞋匠，对吧？所以他被带上法庭指控叛国罪。但基本上，他只是在为主张激进变革而辩护，对吧？我的意思是，他并不主张推翻君主制。但反对这种说法的反论——或者说对立观点——会是，这一切发生在一个国际局势极度动荡的时期。换句话说，这些思想被视为英国正在与之战斗的敌人的思想。是的，我完全理解这一点。
I mean, I see why the charge is brought against him. But the fact remains that in the end, he gets acquitted, doesn't he? Well, you need to rewind a little bit. And Hardy and his associates in the reforming societies, as they were known, were very, very careful not to commit treason. They didn't commit treasonous acts, but they did commit seditious acts. So they were encouraging sort of a rebellion against authority. So that's a good question. Just to focus in on that for a second.
我的意思是，我明白为什么会对她提起指控。但事实仍然是，他最终被判无罪了，不是吗？好吧，你需要把时间倒回一点。哈代和他在改革社团中的同伴们——正如他们所知——非常非常小心，以免犯下叛国罪。他们没有实施叛国行为，但他们的确实施了煽动叛乱的行为。所以他们是在鼓励某种对权威的反叛。所以这是个好问题。我们就把焦点集中在这个问题上一会儿。
Is there a point, I guess this would be the point, that treason and sedition become muddled in the public mind? Hardy is accused of not directly threatening the person of the king, but he wants to radically reform Parliament. The charge against him is that this will inevitably lead to the death
有一个时刻——我想这就是这个时刻——叛国罪和煽动叛乱罪在公众心目中变得混淆了，对吗？哈代被指控的不是直接威胁国王本人，而是他想要彻底改革议会。对他的指控是，这不可避免地会导致
of the king, so his actions are indirectly treasonous. And of course it completely falls apart in court. Which is why it doesn't win. Which is why the prosecution doesn't win. Correct, yeah. So it falls apart. Now they do legislate subsequently, they re-update the treason laws again. Not the Treason
国王的死亡，因此他的行为具有间接的叛国性质。当然，这在法庭上完全站不住脚。这就是为什么它没有胜诉的原因。这就是为什么检方没有胜诉的原因。没错，是的。所以它站不住脚。现在他们随后进行立法，再次更新了叛国法。不是1352年的《叛国法》，
Act of 1352, but they do, the government does update treason laws to try to prevent them losing cases like that again. But the ideas are out there now, and across the 1790s, the thing that makes it very, very difficult for Paine and his colleagues is, of course, war breaking out with France in 1793. So all of a sudden, the ideas they're propagating are in support of an enemy state.
但政府确实更新了叛国法，试图防止他们再次输掉这样的案件。但这些思想现在已经流传开来，在整个1790年代，让潘恩和他的同僚们感到非常非常困难的事情，当然是1793年与法国爆发的战争。所以突然之间，他们正在传播的思想是在支持一个敌对国家。
They're the enemy's ideas, basically. Just on the documents, you've got this sort of, I don't know, it's like a cardboard tray full of stuff. Is that the historian's term, stuff? The cardboard tray full of stuff is the technical, I think you'll find it's the technical, it's the archival term, isn't it, Neil? So these are the papers, these are all the trial papers. This is the evidence that was being gathered against Hardy, and we can see the Treasury Solicitor underlining what they believe to be treasonous,
基本上，它们就是敌人的思想。说到这些文件，你这里有某种，我不知道，就像一个装满东西的纸板托盘。这就是历史学家的专业术语吗，“东西”？这个装满东西的纸板托盘是专业术语，我想你会发现这是档案术语，对吧，尼尔？所以这些是文件，这些都是审判文件。这是针对哈代收集的证据，我们可以看到财政部副检察长在他们认为具有叛国性质的词句下划了线，
or most certainly the seditious paragraphs in Thomas Paine's Rights of Man which is in this pile in front of us and these are read out
或者肯定托马斯·潘恩的《人权论》中具有煽动性的段落，这本书就放在我们面前这堆资料里，这些都被宣读了出来
and the correspondence of the London Corresponding Society and they're read out full of, the trial takes several days which is longer
还有伦敦通讯社的信件，都被宣读了，审判花费了好几天时间，这比当时通常的叛国罪审判要长，
than a treason trial usually takes at the time but we're starting to see the vague emergence of the modern conception of the rule of law. So while they flood the court with what they claim, what the Attorney General claims are treasonous actions
但我们开始看到现代法治概念的模糊萌芽。因此，当他们用他们声称的、总检察长声称是叛国行为
and treasonous words, they're not. And the case does fall apart. But they try to overwhelm nearly the court. But in Ireland it's different because there you have the further dimension of an independence campaign. So in 1798 where you have Irish Rebellion you have Lord Edward Fitzgerald
和叛国言论的文件充斥法庭时，其实并不是。案件确实不攻自破了。但他们几乎试图压倒法庭。但在爱尔兰情况则不同，因为那里有着争取独立的运动这一更深层的维度。因此，在1798年的爱尔兰起诉中，你有爱德华·菲茨杰拉德勋爵，
who I gather is the last person to be attainted. That's right. So it's a posthumous act of attainment, isn't it? The goals didn't start out that way. As I say, initially it was the idea for parliamentary reform, but the leaders of the United Irishmen were politically neutered in the mid-1790s and Tone
据我所知，他是最后一个被剥夺公民权的人。没错。所以这是一个追溯性的剥夺公民权法案，对吧？最初的目标并不是这样的。正如我所说，最初的想法是为了议会改革，但在1790年代中期，联合爱尔兰人社团的领导人在政治上被阉割了，而托恩
is accused of treason. The government in Dublin can't make the charges stick, but he's allowed to go into exile. He goes to the United States in the hope of encouraging American support for an Irish movement. What becomes a Republican movement. It's not initially, but this is what it becomes.
被指控犯有叛国罪。都柏林的政府无法做实这些指控，但他被允许流亡。他前往美国，希望争取美国对爱尔兰运动的支持。演变成一场共和主义运动。最初并不是这样，但这正是它后来的发展方向。
And Tone is deeply disappointed in what he sees as the mercantilism of the Americans. He's deeply disappointed in George Washington himself and Jefferson. So he goes to France and he seeks help from Britain's other enemy, Napoleon Bonaparte at this point.
托恩对他在美国人身上看到的商业主义感到深感失望。他对乔治·华盛顿本人和杰斐逊也深感失望。因此他去了法国，并在这个时候寻求英国的另一个敌人拿破仑·波拿巴的帮助。
And we find Tone seeking and pleading. He becomes an officer in the French army. He's given French citizenship and he's hoping... That is, from the standards of London, pretty treasonous behavior. Most certainly.
我们发现托恩四处寻求和恳求。他成为了法国军队的一名军官。他被授予法国国籍，并且他希望……从伦敦的标准来看，这相当于是叛国行为。当然。为了公平起见。他……这简直是针锋相对。从伦敦的标准来看，这相当于是叛国行为。当然。为了公平起见。而且他，这简直是针锋相对。是的。并且他正试图争取法国的入侵部队。与此同时，爱尔兰的联合爱尔兰人社团已经变成了一个秘密组织，它正试图建立一个地下运动，当法国人到达时，英国政府将被推翻，爱尔兰将成为一个共和国
To be fair. And he's... It's almost one in the eye. That is, from the standards of London, pretty treasonous behavior. Most certainly. To be fair. And he's, it's almost one in the eye. Yeah. And he is trying to secure a French invasion force. At the same time, the United Irishmen in Ireland has become a secret organization, and it's trying to create an underground movement that when the French arrive, there will be, the British government will be overthrown and Ireland will become a republic
一个自主的共和国，而托恩被捕了，在1798年夏季由菲茨杰拉德及其在联合爱尔兰人社团中的同伙领导的起诉爆发时，他实际上被打了个措手不及，但它
a self-determining republic and Tone is caught he's caught on the hop effectively in the summer of 1798 when the rebellion does break out led by Fitzgerald and his accomplices in the United Irishmen but it's
很快就被镇压了。法国人曾试图在1796年底入侵，但他们没能登陆。1796年12月，一支舰队从布雷斯特出发，企图在班特里湾登陆，但海浪太大，风暴太猛
quickly quashed. The French had tried to invade at the end of 1796 but they couldn't land. In December 1796 a fleet had been sent from Brest to land at Bantry Bay but the seas were too high, the storms were too big
所以舰队不得不放弃，随后英国人尽一切努力确保一支舰队无法在不为人知的情况下再次直接航行到爱尔兰，而且正如我所说，联合爱尔兰人社团
so the fleet had to abandon and the British then made every effort to ensure that a fleet couldn't sail directly to Ireland again without being known about and that as I say the United Irishmen
作为一个政治组织已经被阉割了。
had been neutered as a political organisation. So could I, just on the theme of republicanism I mean to argue for a republic is by definition I guess to be hostile to a monarchy and therefore inherently treasonous. At what point does arguing for a republic
所以我想问，就共和主义这个主题而言，我的意思是，主张建立共和国，按定义我猜就是对君主制充满敌意，因此本质上就是叛国。在哪个节点上，主张建立共和国
cease to be seen as treasonous by the government? It doesn't really. You know, if we look at 1916, the men who fought, men and women who fought in the 1960s to rising in 1916, they're all so... But I'm not talking just specifically in the Irish context, more generally in the British context.
政府不再视之为叛国罪？其实并没有。你知道，如果我们看看1916年，那些战斗的人，在1960年代参与1916年起义的男男女女，他们都那么……但我指的不仅是爱尔兰语境下的，更泛指英国语境下的。
But some in the reign of Queen Victoria, there are lots of Republicans. There's a lot of Republicans. Presumably anyone who's arguing for a republic in the reign of Queen Victoria, say, is committing treason, aren't they? Under the wording of the Act, yes. But it's much more difficult to prosecute. So the crown shies away from it in many ways.
但在维多利亚女王统治时期，有很多共和党人。有很多共和党人。据推测，在维多利亚女王统治时期主张建立共和国的人，比方说，是在犯叛国罪，对吧？按照该法案的字面意思是这样的。但起诉要困难得多。因此，王室在很多方面都对此退避三舍。
Not entirely, but these ideas are out there now. There's so many people. So there's an acceptance that basically it's simple practicality, that there's so many people believe in the republic now in republicanism now that it's simply there's there's no way you can prosecute everybody who believes that to a point yes and also the loyalism in in britain loyalty to the crown is also a hugely powerful political uh hugely powerful political force so it's it's it's a real dichotomy. If we look at the risings that happen, or the attempted risings, and the conspiracies, the Cato Street conspiracy, the Newport Rising,
并非完全如此，但这些想法现在已经存在了。有这么多人。因此人们接受了这样一种观念：这基本上是一个简单的实用主义问题，现在有这么多人都相信共和国，相信共和主义，所以根本没有办法起诉每一个有这种信仰的人，在某种程度上是的，而且英国的忠君主义，对王室的忠诚，也是一种极其强大的政治力量——极其强大的政治力量，所以这真是一个二分法。如果我们看看发生的起义，或者未遂起义和阴谋，卡托街阴谋、纽波特起义，
1848 in France, and then how it spills over into Britain, these fears of monarchical overthrow, they don't go away, and people are prosecuted. But it continues to be propagated by the ideas of the French Revolution and by Paine and by Hardy.
1848年的法国，以及它是如何蔓延到英国的，对推翻君主制的恐惧并没有消失，人们也受到了起诉。但它继续受到法国大革命思想、潘恩和哈代的思想的传播。
But there's a general sense that the act of treason, although it remains on the statute book, is becoming, it's too kind of nebulous a thing to hold legal water. And is that why over the course of nebulous a thing to to help to hold legal water and is that why over the course of the 20th century even against the backdrop of growing republicanism of ireland becoming independent and so on that you see the the um the act of treason used less and less and i'm right that the very last person to be executed for treason in britain is william
但普遍的看法是，叛国罪虽然仍然保留在法规中，但正变得过于模糊，无法在法律上站住脚。这就是为什么在20世纪的进程中，甚至在日益高涨的共和主义背景下，爱尔兰变得独立等等背景下，你会发现叛国罪法案的使用越来越少，我是对的吗，英国最后一个因叛国罪被处决的人是威廉·
joyce better known as lord hor haw is that right that's correct yeah so what's about what's and that is done essentially on a legal technicality isn't it because it turns out he's not even a british citizen so joyce was born in brooklyn but he falsified documents to get a british passport so this was how the court in taking out a passport you are claiming allegiance to the crown and we should we should just say for those who don't know about him that he he goes to nazi germany and he broadcasts to britain from germany throughout the war and so when he's captured after the war it looks a kind of open and shut case it must have done well he disputed that he said he hadn't committed treason
乔伊斯，也就是人们熟知的“霍霍勋爵”，对吗？完全正确。那么，这是怎么回事，这基本上是一个法律技术问题，对吗？因为结果证明他甚至都不是英国公民。所以乔伊斯出生在布鲁克林，但他伪造了文件以获得英国护照，这就是法院认定的，在申请护照时，你宣称效忠于王室。我们应该顺便对那些不了解他的人说，他去了纳粹德国，并在整个战争期间从德国向英国进行广播。因此，当他在战后被俘时，这看起来像是一个水落石出的案件，一定是的。嗯，他对此提出了异议，他说他没有犯叛国罪，
but of course he had you know so it's the treason legislation, the 1352 legislation becomes much, much harder to prosecute people under. There's also the peril for a government of conducting a trial in open court because it allows people to defend themselves and produce their own evidence under the. Because there are no bills of attainder. I mean, is that simply because they have become illegal? I mean, no one would dream of bringing an attainder. I mean, is that simply because they have become illegal? I mean, no one would dream of bringing an attainder against someone now. I can think of loads of people
但当然他确实犯了，你知道的，所以叛国罪立法，1352年的立法，让人很难再以此起诉任何人。对于政府来说，在公开法庭上进行审判也存在风险，因为它允许人们为自己辩护并出示自己的证据。因为没有剥夺公权法案。我的意思是，这仅仅是因为它们已经变得不合法了吗？我的意思是，没有人会梦想提出剥夺公权法案。我的意思是，这仅仅是因为它们已经变得不合法了吗？我的意思是，没有人会梦想对现在的某人提出剥夺公权法案。我能想到很多
who would bring a bill of attainder against. I mean, is the opportunity to do that still on the statute book? As far as I'm aware, I think the last, you know, people like Churchill during the war and as the tide of the war was turning during the Second World War,
会对……提出剥夺公权法案的人。我的意思是，这样做的机会仍然在法案中吗？据我所知，我认为最后一次，你知道，像丘吉尔在战争期间，以及当二战期间战争局势发生逆转时，
Churchill, they were trying to deal with the question of what on earth are we going to do with the Nazi leaders? How are we going to deal with these men if we capture them? What will we do with Hitler? What court can try Hitler? So initially it was put to Churchill that, well, we could attain to him. And of course he scoffed at it. He dismissed the idea. Could the British Parliament attain to Hitler?
丘吉尔，他们正试图处理这样一个问题：我们到底该拿纳粹头目怎么办？如果我们抓住了这些人，我们要怎么处置他们？我们该如何处置希特勒？什么法院能审判希特勒？所以最初有人向丘吉尔提出，我们可以剥夺他的公民权。当然，他对这种想法嗤之以鼻。他驳回了这个想法。英国议会能剥夺希特勒的公民权吗？
Yes, it could. Wow. Yeah. I think in the eyes of the world, that might loom. So we've got one last document, which I know you picked out for us. So we just need to rewind a little bit from Lord Haw Haw. So in the First World War, again, from London's perspective, this looks like a real open and shut case of treason.
是的，可以。哇。是的。我想在世人眼中，这可能会隐现。所以我们还有最后一份文件，我知道你为我们挑选了这份文件。所以我们需要将磁带从“霍霍勋爵”那里稍微倒回一点。在第一次世界大战中，同样从伦敦的角度来看，这看起来像是叛国罪的一个水落石出的案件。
But I'm imagining you're going to see it differently, which is why you picked it out. So this is the Easter Rising, 1916. And obviously, as a Dubliner, you've got a particular stake in this. I'm also a historian, and I can distance myself from it in some ways. But what we have in the collection that we found is the bottom half of the proclamation, the 1916 proclamation that Patrick Pearce read out from the steps of the GPO, the General Post Office on Sackville Street, what's now O'Connell Street in Dublin.
但我猜你的看法会不同，这也是你挑选它的原因。这就是1916年的复活节起义。显然，作为一个都柏林人，你对此有着特殊的利害关系。我也是一名历史学家，在某种程度上我可以与之保持距离。但我们在我们找到的藏品中拥有的是宣言的下半部分，即帕特里克·皮尔斯在都柏林萨克维尔街（现在的奥康奈尔街）的GPO（邮政总局）台阶上宣读的1916年宣言。
And there's a wonderful story about this document in that the type had been confiscated to print the document a few days before the Rising was to break out. So they had to quickly get another set of type, but they only had enough to print the top half of the document and they reamed off how many copies of everything they did and then they reset the type and printed the bottom half and they left the type in the machine and they ran around the corner and that was printed in liberty hall in dublin right on the liffey the very tall building now on the liffey and uh when the brit forces re-secured Dublin a few days later, they go into Liberty Hall and they find the printing press
关于这份文件有一个精彩的故事，那就是在起义爆发前几天，印刷这份文件的铅字被没收了。所以他们不得不赶紧弄另一套铅字，但他们只有足够的铅字来印刷文件的上半部分，他们印刷了无数份他们所做的一切，然后他们重新排版并印刷了下半部分，他们把铅字留在机器里，然后跑到拐角处，那是在都柏林的自由大厅印刷的，就在利菲河畔，现在利菲河畔那座非常高的大楼里，呃，几天后，当英国军队重新夺回都柏林时，他们进入自由大厅，找到了印刷机，
that the 1916 proclamation was produced on. And they produce several more copies. And that ended up in Sean McDiarmid's court martial. So martial law is imposed upon Ireland after the Easter Rising breaks out, which is why the rebels, the leaders as they were, are tried by court martial. And they're tried and executed in secret as opposed to giving them an opportunity to air their views in public or their raison d'etre or their reasons for rebelling. And the papers there you can see in front of you are from the courts, Marshall, that were conducted against the rebel leaders. So these are the official records.
1916年宣言就是在这台印刷机上印制的。他们又印了好几份。这最终成了肖·麦克德马特的军事法庭审判材料。因此，复活节起义爆发后，爱尔兰实施了军事管制，这就是为什么叛军，也就是当时的领袖们，要接受军事法庭的审判。他们被秘密审判并处决，而不是让他们有机会在公众面前发表他们的观点、他们的存在理由或他们叛乱的理由。你面前看到的那些文件来自对叛军领袖进行的军事法庭审判。所以这些是官方记录。
Most certainly, yeah. And the handwriting. So some of them are typed and there's handwriting scribbled on this one that you've got to open at. So what's the handwriting all about? The writing is just, you know, the court, the court, Marshall, gathering evidence as quickly as it can
当然，是的。还有笔迹。其中一些是打字出来的，你打开的那份上面有潦草的笔迹。那么这些笔迹是怎么回事？这些字迹只是，你知道的，法庭，法庭，军事法庭，正以尽可能快的速度收集证据，
and drawing in all the intelligence reports that had been produced in the months and years subsequent um uh i mean previous and um they're being laid out for the court yeah so to overwhelmingly prove guilt yeah i mean no one we wouldn't i mean no one normally no no reasonably sane person would think of this as a case of treason now, I suppose, would they? Well, this is something that we see certainly with those who had rebelled in Ireland. They see themselves as fighting a war. That they weren't loyal to the crown, so they weren't committing treason.
并汇集了在随后的几个月和几年里制作的所有情报报告，呃，也就是以前的，呃，它们正在提交给法庭，是的，以便压倒性地证明有罪，是的。我的意思是，没有人，我们不会，我的意思是，现在没有人，没有一个理智正常的人会把这当作叛国罪的案件，我想，会吗？嗯，这确实是我们从那些在爱尔兰叛乱的人身上看到的情况。他们认为自己是在打仗。他们不忠于王室，所以他们没有犯叛国罪。
They were seeking independence. So, I mean, one case I do know, I mean, in 1981, the Queen is doing the trooping of the color and a man comes out of the crowd and fires six blank bullets at her. And he is charged with treason, isn't he? And that is presumably because he is directly targeting the figure of the monarch. So in a way, we're going back to the medieval understanding that actually treason laws can be applied when the subjects of a monarch are targeting the person of the monarch. Intercharging under the 1352 legislation, yeah. But otherwise it's too cumbersome a mechanism to apply.
他们在寻求独立。所以，我的意思是，我确实知道的一个案子是，在1981年，女王正在进行皇家阅兵式，一个人从人群中走出来，向她开了六颗空包弹。他被控叛国罪，对吧？这大概是因为他直接把目标对准了君主的形象。所以从某种程度上说，我们回到了中世纪的理解，即当君主的臣民将目标对准君主本人时，叛国法实际上是可以适用的。根据1352年的立法进行指控，是的。但除此之外，它是一个太繁琐的适用机制。
It's nebulous. It's not guaranteed to return a verdict of guilt. And there is also other legislation that can be used at this point. So the Crown doesn't... Can I ask you a question? You may not want to answer this question, but right at the beginning of these two episodes,
它很模糊。它不能保证得出有罪的判决。此时还可以使用其他立法。所以王室并不……我能问你一个问题吗？你可能不想回答这个问题，但就在这两集的开头，
I read from an article that the government is planning to refine and reframe the treason law. Do you think that the treason law is redeemable, that it can be changed adequately? Or is that not a question that you can answer? I wouldn't feel I'm qualified to answer it. What I can say, it won't be the first time
我读到一篇文章说，政府正计划修正和重构叛国法。你认为叛国法是可以挽救的，它可以得到充分的修改吗？还是说这不是一个你能回答的问题？我觉得自己没有资格回答这个问题。我能说的是，这并非政府第一次
that a government has tried to not amend the original law, but update the terms in which a government makes it useful to them. So we see it throughout the century, like this act sitting here right in front of me. You know, they are... That's the Act of Indemnity, written by Charles II. Yeah, there is a law that emerges in 1661 which redefines treason that says you cannot even seek
试图不去修改最初的法律，而是更新政府使其对自己有用的条款。所以我们在整个世纪里都能看到这一点，就像这份就摆在我面前的法案一样。你知道，它们是……那是查理二世撰写的《豁免法》。是的，1661年出现了一项重新定义叛国罪的法律，其中规定你甚至不能企图
to harm the person of the king, Charles II. So governments throughout the centuries really have have tried to do this um update the law to the circumstances of the time neil this has been absolutely fascinating and so many i mean tom you and i were looking at the documents before we before we started recording and it's it's an amazing privilege to be able to look at the sort of you know the the handwriting on the parchment or the paper um and the popish plot or whatever now when we ended the previous episode we asked ewan to identify one person whom he would save and one case of treason which you know he would definitely be the hanging judge so it would be
伤害国王查理二世本人。因此，几个世纪以来的政府确实一直在这样做——根据当时的时代环境更新法律。尼尔，这绝对太迷人了，而且有那么多——我是说，汤姆，在你我开始录制之前，我们一直在看这些文件，能够看到诸如羊皮纸或纸张上的笔迹之类的东西，真是一种令人惊叹的特权，无论是波普阴谋还是别的什么。现在，在我们结束上一集时，我们请尤恩指出一个他会拯救的人，以及一个他肯定会充当绞刑法官的叛国罪案件，
remiss of us not to ask you the same question, Neil. I can tell you who I'd get rid of. Who would you get rid of? Oliver Cromwell, done. Bang, gone. He's not even on trial. What are you talking about? You know. You dig him up. This is shocking. On London Bridge. In terms of saving, actually, I do think I
如果我们不问你同样的问题，尼尔，那就太失职了。我可以告诉你我会除掉谁。你会除掉谁？奥利弗·克伦威尔，完事。砰，没了。他甚至都没受审。你在说什么呢？你知道的。把他挖出来。这太令人震惊了。在伦敦桥上。至于拯救，其实我确实认为我
know who I would save. And in 1916, some men went into battle intending to die. The leaders, the signatories of the 1916 proclamation, they all expected to die should they lose. But
知道我会拯救谁。在1916年，一些人抱着必死的决心投入战斗。领袖们，1916年宣言的签署人，如果失败了，他们都预料到自己会死。但
the president of the proclaimed republic, Patrick Pearce, his brother Willie was executed, tried and executed, and he probably shouldn't have been. So I would save Willie Pearce. Why Willie was executed tried and executed and he probably shouldn't have been so I would save Willie Pearce
被宣称的共和国总统帕特里克·皮尔斯，他的弟弟威利被处决了，经过审判并被处决了，而他本不该被处决的。所以我将拯救威利·皮尔斯。为什么威利被处决了，经过审判并被处决了，而他本不该被处决的，所以我将拯救威利·皮尔斯。
why would you say why him and not the others because he was he's in the wrong place at the wrong time no he was very junior he just had the wrong surname you've only allowed him one
你为什么要说为什么是他而不是其他人？因为他，他在错误的时间出现在了错误的地方。不，他资历很浅，他只是有个错误的姓氏。你只允许他选一个。
I haven't well I have only allowed him one I mean I'm so shocked by that Cromwell thing I can barely bring myself to but I will do it because I'm a professional I will tell people
我没有——好吧，我确实只允许他选一个。我的意思是，我对克伦威尔的事感到太震惊了，我简直无法面对，但我会这么做，因为我是一个专业人士，我会告诉人们
this is a brilliant exhibition. Neely's done a fantastic tour for us. The Cromwellian heresy aside. So Tom, this is at the National Archives, isn't it? It's from the 5th of November. What other date could it be? 2022, obviously. It's amazing to see all the documents.
这是一个精彩的展览。尼尔为我们做了一次棒极了的游览。抛开克伦威尔的异端邪说不谈。那么汤姆，这是在国家档案馆，对吧？是从11月5日开始的。还能是什么日子？2022年，显而易见。看到所有的文件真是太棒了。
Tom, does it cost any money to go to this exhibition? You know, Dominic, it costs zero pounds. Do I need to book beforehand? You do not need to book. Wow, does it cost any money to go to this exhibition? You know, Dominic, it costs zero pounds. Do I need to book beforehand? You do not need to book. Wow, fantastic. Dominic, is there a book that goes with the exhibition? You know, there's a website. There is a website. Nationalarchives.gov.uk slash treason, but more
汤姆，去这个展览要花钱吗？你知道的，多米尼克，只要零英镑。我需要提前预订吗？你不需要预订。哇，去这个展览要花钱吗？你知道的，多米尼克，只要零英镑。我需要提前预订吗？你不需要预订。哇，太棒了。多米尼克，有没有一本与展览配套的书？你知道，有一个网站。有一个网站。nationalarchives.gov.uk/treason，但更
excitingly, there is a book. Are you in this book, Neil? I wrote a book. I co-wrote it. Oh, gee. Are you talking about Cromwell in it? He gets a mention, yeah you don't like dominic i i read it and it's absolutely fine does he behaves himself yeah great well so the book has the tom holland seal of approval for what that's worth uh it's called history of treason the bloody history of britain through the stories of its most notorious traitors the exhibition it's running until the end of the year. Beyond? It runs until April.
令人兴奋的是，有一本书。尼尔，你在这本书里吗？我写了一本书。我合著的。哦，天哪。你在里面谈论克伦威尔了吗？他被提到了，是的。你不喜欢多米尼克，我读了，它完全没问题。他表现得很好吗？是的，太好了。所以这本书得到了汤姆·霍兰的盖章认可，不管这有什么价值。它叫《叛国史：通过其最臭名昭著的叛徒的故事看英国的血腥历史》。这个展览一直持续到年底。之后呢？一直持续到四月。
Oh my God. Is there any excuse for people to miss it? I don't think so. It's really good. It shows off the breadth and the wealth
哦，天哪。人们有什么借口错过它吗？我不这么认为。这真的很棒。它展示了国家档案馆馆藏的广度、
and the depth of the collections here at the National Archives. So do come along and see. We've done our best to interpret it for you and bring you on
丰富度和深度。所以一定要来看看。我们已经尽力为你解读，并带你踏上
the journey of treason across the centuries from the 1352 Act onwards. Tom, it would be treason to miss it. Not to come. It would be on that bombshell. Thank you, Neil. Thank you to the National Archives
跨越几个世纪的叛国之旅，从1352年的法案开始。汤姆，错过它将是叛国。不来就太遗憾了。带着这个重磅消息。谢谢你，尼尔。感谢国家档案馆
for having us and thank you for listening. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishtertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
接待我们，谢谢你们的收听。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听奖励剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishtertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。